c'est propre c'est ce sont des propos
qui pour moi sont parfaitement choquant
et en toute hypothèse ne devrait pas
être tenu par la prison a rappelé quels
qu'ils soient
parce qu'il incarne fonctions il a un
rôle de rassemblement de la nation et en
aucun cas il ne peut quelles que soient
les raisons d'ailleurs se comporter de
la sorte et finalement discriminer une
partie de la population je ne suis pas
en accord avec ceux qui refusent le
vaccin je pense que c'est un choix qui
l'aurait personnel certes mais il n'est
pas sans conséquence le savons tous et
notamment dans le travail exorbitants
que doivent donner le monde les hôpitaux
et le monde de la santé en particulier
mais c'est pas pour autant que malgré ce
désaccord que j'ai avec les anti pacs je
suis dans une situation de tenir de tels
propos dont je pense que c'est
inadmissible en réalité il peut y avoir
un calcul politicien là derrière dans
toute hypothèse il n'est pas acceptable
et c'est pas de la hauteur d'un
président de la république en tous les
cas de l'idée que je me fais du présent
de la rue
[Musique]